[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
son monde à lui c'est le dessin depuis
toujours le dessin de presse la
caricature la sculpture aussi ses
oeuvres interroge l'actualité mais aussi
l'histoire la grande histoire depuis
près de 50 ans son coup de crayon c'est
frapper là où ça fait mal là où ça
dérange il collectionne les prix et les
marques de reconnaissance dans le monde
entier il a fait de son art une arme
pour défendre la liberté d'expression la
liberté de la presse même dans des pays
où on la regarde avec méfiance cette
liberté il a pris sa retraite depuis
quelques temps mais at-il ranger son
crayon pour autant on ne les imagine pas
un instant mais on va lui poser la
question ce sera beaucoup plus simple
bienvenue dans un monde un regard
bienvenue plantu et merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation dans ce lieu
magnifique qu'est le dôme tournons un
lieu méconnu du sénat que le grand
public découvre notamment avec vous je
précise que vous êtes notamment l'auteur
de l'année 2021 vu par plantu chez
calmann lévy est-ce que j'ai raison vous
ne l'avez pas du tout ranger ce crayon
vous ne le changerez jamais rien été
c'est comme si je vous disais d'abord
merci de m'accueillir et puis c'est
comme si je vous disais or finalement
l'oxygène hommes vous avez encore besoin
bon bah moi je
respire puis j'aime l'odeur du feu
j'aime ça sent un peu l'alcool je vais
une fois j'avais fait une émission à
nulle part ailleurs payal gildas qui est
dit mais quel connard qui venu avec une
mobylette en fait c'était ça qui santé
mais j'adore l'odeur alors que je n'y
peux rien je lis sauf que vous êtes
comme je le disais à la retraite ce qui
veut rien dire pour vous mais ce que
vous dessinez aujourd'hui finalement
pour vous pour nous plus librement pour
les soignants aussi oui pour les
soignants je fais beaucoup de de dessin
pour les soignants j'en suis à mon 31
l'hôpital voulait trouver dans quel état
les soignants
30 l'exemple
comme vous savez quand on a regardé le
14 juillet ya plus d'un an de 2020 il ya
un moment devant macron il y avait tous
les soignants qui étaient là des
infirmières des médecins des
ambulanciers et au moment de la
marseillaise qui était joué pour eux
j'ai été habité par cette émotion parce
qu'ils ont tellement vécu de choses
incroyables que il faut avoir ça en tête
et al'avantage de faire ses dessins dans
les hôpitaux c'est que moi je trouve ça
mignon de voir après les dessins avec
les infirmières dans les couloirs et en
fait là elles sourient elles sont
mignonnes elle sourit mais en parallèle
on masque un mais on imagine que oui oui
oui non non c'est sympa mais en fait je
me rends compte que ça a été des drames
et par exemple le drame qu'on me raconte
souvent c'est qu'est-ce qu'on fait les
familles qui arrivent au tout début en
janvier février 2020 au tout début les
familles est ce qu'on les fait venir
et ça je trouve que c'est passionnant et
j'ai passé ma vie j'ai raté mes études
au début mais j'ai passé ma vie à poser
des questions à des journalistes à d et
alors ils m'ont toujours raconter des
tas de trucs et je me suis comme une
éponge me suis impressionné de tout ce
qu'il me disait egée et tanger pas fait
un dessin sur le sujet j'ai pas bien
compris le sujet c'est pour ça que pour
mieux répondre à votre question même si
j'ai arrêté de travailler au bout de
cinquante ans au monde je continue à
faire mes dessins mais dès que j'entends
de tout à l'heure des gt
j'entendais la radio ou la messagerie le
dessiner et donc comme j'ai une mémoire
épouvantable je me suis envoyé un mail
ou un texto la nuit je m'envoie des
textos et je leur ai je regarde le matin
temps n'importe comment que cette
exposition cette une du monde qui vous
était aussi mon père et moi je suis
exposé partout maintenant et en plus il
ya des expos avec rza où on fait un
bouquin et des expos avec réserves ont
fait ça chez gallimard crée vraiment
j'ai donc que je fais plus à la une du
journal je le fais dans les rues et
c'est très intéressant pour un
dessinateur vanier au moment où il ya
des peurs qui se sont installés dans
notre société où la démocratie est en
train de bouger de basculer on se dit ah
ouais mais ça non là les attaques
destinées à barbu oui mais là il ya une
minarets ou la hyène synagogue fais
gaffe tous ses pôles du met les pieds
bah oui mais je le fais quand même dans
la rue je faisais des dessins partout et
les gens ils réagissent ils sont dans la
rue ah oui il ya ça et ça me plait
dessin fait partie de vous depuis
toujours c'est ce que je disais en
présentation du show ça vous vienne qui
je lisais que votre père était
dessinateur industriel allemand est ce
que ça peut devenir un peu de lui un peu
aussi de votre mère qui apparemment
n'avait pas sa langue dans sa poche
c'est ce que la caricature email elle
n'était pas toujours jean clip i'm rld
elle disait tu vois c'est là j'ai pas
quel âge là mais elle ne fait plus et je
trouvais ça méchant mais à la fois nous
est ce assez drôle c'est pas très
généreux
ça me fait rire et il était pas emballer
vos parents contre j'en ai dit que vous
vouliez faire du dessin je crois qu'ils
ont inscrits en école de médecine
sebhaoui alors qu'est ce que vous leur
avez répondu bah que je préférais faire
du dessin j'étais très obéissants donc
je vais quand même faire la médecine bah
oui mais comme j'étais nul j'ai raté
afin de bout de deux ans j'ai redoublé
et puis après je le dis souvent dans les
écoles surtout faites pas comme moi j'ai
réveillé mes parents la nuit je leur ai
dit
je vous à faire
du dessin joue à faire du théâtre ou du
coup tu vas te coucher et puis un jour
je leur ai dit ben voilà j'arrête
médecine
je vais aller à bruxelles parce que
c'était la seule école de bd à l'époque
à bruxelles et puis je leur ai dit en
plus je vais me marier et en plus pas
l'église donc c'est pas bon plan comme
voile et aménager l'impôt par an je n'ai
pas fait exprès était il fallait que ça
sorte jeu comme au dessin c'est comme un
dessin est très vite à bruxelles vous
allez vous servir de votre savoir faire
de votre arbre pour gagner votre vie ça
commence là bas bah oui ça a été facile
en fait ça pas été si difficile que ça
je laisserai avec voyez j'ai vendu des
meubles aux grilles lafayette
j'avais des escabeaux j'étais très bon
vendeur d'escabeau mais
moi ma passion c'était vraiment le
dessin voyez quand je vous vois vous
m'écoutez et puis vous montrer avec vos
yeux non je t'écoute bien je me suis
concentré dont vous baissez les
paupières et moi j'adore
et je le vois vos dents
mais non mais en voyant vos dents je
vois la largeur du sourire je vois le
dessin qu'on peut faire c'est fatigant
c'est c'est génial si rigolo mais à la
fois qu'est-ce qui m'a posé comme tesson
la fille je sais plus avec en rdc pour
ça
c'est parce qu'en fait je suis toujours
dans le dessin toujours et qu'est ce qui
fait que le monde vos repères comment se
passe la personne me repérer qu'est ce
qui vous est
imparti oui je jeu
aux galeries lafayette survenue après à
paris et au carnet fayette à la pause de
11 heures de télé phone est parce que
dans la nuit j'avais déposé des dessins
dans le journal que j'aime je mets le
monde et est à 11 heures je téléphonais
à un rédacteur en chef qui s'appelle
bernard lausanne et hawaï et mais c'est
oui c'est vous qui avait déposé les
dessins oui mais je n'aime voir
moi je connaissais personne m'a le monde
de la presse là quand je vois les médias
tout ça maintenant c'est ma famille mais
à la fois à l'époque je me laissais rien
et donc
il ya très franchement c'est là où la
chance mon info à la chance ou est
tenace suscite la chance si la chance
vous et personne ne m'attendait et puis
j'ai été reçu donc pas rédacteur en chef
qui a regardé mes dessins il m'a dit oui
ça c'est bien ouais ça ouais peut-être
mais revenu tard pendant des mois j'ai
j'ai envoyé plein de dessins et puis un
jour
en 72 en 1972 j'ai téléphoné et il m'a
dit ben oui le dessin il passe sur le
site et sur le vietnam et donc il ya un
dessin qui est passé et puis après deux
la p3 puis après j'ai compris que je
faisais un métier d'après les hommes
politiques ils m'ont pris au sérieux on
va y venir c'est intéressant votre
historique lier votre président ici au
sénat ah c'était mignon que ya longtemps
gérard larcher ouais la première version
larcher il m'invite à déjeuner en chimie
si vous avez vu ma chaise mon fauteuil
il dit si ben oui bah c'est la fauteuil
et oui il a pas de roulette et pourrait
vous dessiner les sénateurs avec des
roulettes si on était en attraper
qu'est-ce qu'on fait des blagues
j'ai adoré ça c'est bien c'est bien
quand les les femmes ou les hommes petit
qui rentre dans les dessins et puis et
puis on sent que ça asticoter c'est fait
pour ça pour revenir sur votre premier
d'essence celui dont vous parliez qui a
été publiée par le monde le tout premier
1er octobre 72 y avait une collomb c'est
une coulon avec un point d'interrogation
dans le vix a aussi sa a fortement
marqué les esprits et c'est resté un
oiseau qui vous a accompagnés tout au
long de votre carrière pourquoi sept
colons bob scams écrit comme ça de tout
ça il est tout petit voyez il fait 4 à 4
centièmes et ennemi
c'est pas énorme et là on est homo
qu'est-ce qui me pour bien répondre à
votre question il ya les accords sur le
vietnam s'appelle les accords de paris
entre les vietnamiens et les américains
c'est à paris et puis j'ai en tête quand
même tous les défilés dans paris halte à
la guerre au vietnam
je me dis tiens je vais comme on sait
pas ce que ça va donner on est en 72 la
chute de saigon ses 75 donc ces trois
ans avant dit bon je veux faire une
colombe comme ça ah ben je lui mettre un
petit savez c'est le boulot du
dessinateur c'est une réflexion
comme vous dans votre tête sauf que ce
que je vais le faire et est en fait
c'est à force de l'enfant tout de suite
quoi oui et puis voyez mes colombiens
ont changé avec le temps je les destine
plus comme ça mais c'est pas grave et
puis le dessin il est publié et puis je
me dis tiens à willisau l'air de me
prendre j'ai passé ma vie à être étonné
qu'on prenne au sérieux lorsque vous
bousculez c'est parce que vous
interrogez parce que vous déranger que
je vous fait repérer à la fois par un
média le monde effectivement mais aussi
par un public non voulues percuté ce
public je le vous percutez voulez-vous
oui mais c'est après que je mange mal je
le sais pas au départ au début moi je
veux je prends moi je veux faire des
dessins
quand l'ayatollah comme unis
qui est persuadé qu'ils discutent avec
le ciel je me dis tiens je vais dire le
ciel avec un téléphone tout ça mais vous
allez même devenir un dessinateur
redouté par les responsables politiques
ce qui ce qui m'est fait ce qu'ils
voudraient c'est pas juste sur dix ça
était jouissif parfois même d'avoir ce
petit pouvoir sur eux très honnêtement
me sentir que vous aviez un pouvoir sur
eux sur leur image sans leur coach
heureux ceux qui m'ont toujours dit non
j'ai jamais cru ça j'ai jamais cru là je
vais vous montrer un dessin
sur la mort de mitterrand qui est pas
passé pour vous dire que quand on fait
un des
sujets non vous allez comprendre
pourquoi tiens non mais t'as des chefs
on est en janvier
1996 vous êtes ma rédacteur en chef vous
me téléphoner il est 11 heures du matin
j'ai fait un dessin et vous ne dites
mitterrand vient de mourir et je dis
est longue le choc et puis je dit
ils vont me dit tu un quart d'heure pour
faire ton dessin jeudi mitterrand et
vous me répondez ça fait six mois qu'on
te dit qu'il est mourant taped pu
préparer quelque chose donc je prépare
un truc au moment où on dit qu'il ya un
scandale politique et
sociologique sur le détournement
d'argent pour le cancer il y avait une
association qui s'appelait l'arc qui
détournait l'argent donc j'en vois ce
dessin là alors vous rédactrice en chef
cheikh rebecca var et des réticences m
on est en 1996 mitterrand vient de
mourir alors qu'est ce que vous dites
non dits n'ont donc pas maintenant alors
ils sont bien alors ils sont en reparle
dans quelques années mais pas encore ils
sont plus malins que vous monde ils sont
plus vicieux aussi et que je balance
plein de dessins alors j'en écoute alors
on a reçu cinq dessins ils sont super
mais c'est ça on attend que 6e
c'est ça le truc alors j'ai fait un
autre dessin voilà aussi et donc c'est
comme ça tout le temps et royaume forme
ce vieux dessins qui est des années 80
on parle pas encore d'écologie tous les
jours mais à la fois quand je le regarde
avec le temps je me dis tiens mais ça
c'est grâce aux journalistes moi moi je
l'écologie d'enchaîner quatre heures je
connais rien et même encore aujourd'hui
je peux je leur dis pas mais
non j'y connais rien mais j'aime
traduire et j'aime traduire la passion
des autres les patients des journalistes
qui sont passionnés par la chine par
l'europe le nord- sud où disait le tiers
monde à l'époque et moi j'aime traduire
ces chiens d'interprète alors je parle
et quand même de censure ou d'auto
censure parce que j'ai cru comprendre
que ce n'était pas un gros mot pour vous
de parler d'auto censure en 2006 vous
avez pris une position qui vous a
d'ailleurs attiré pas mal de reproches
de la part de vos pairs sur la
publication des caricatures de mahomet
est vous avait invoqué je cite la
responsabilité journalistique du
destinateur et vous vous êtes attiré pas
mal d'animosité de la marde du monde
dans lequel vous évoluez est-ce que vous
maintenez est-ce que vous avez regretté
d'avoir dit ça est ce que vous avez été
mal compris vous avez été très bien
compris vous l'assuré à l'instant quand
vous dites web le dessin la ba oui mais
non ça s'appelle la responsabilité
d'aller qu'on se met à la place des
lecteurs est donc dans ces cas là je me
débrouille toujours pour faire
comprendre faire un dessin évidemment
hommage
au dessinateur qui ont été assassinés je
connaissais tout ce qu'un jour avant
j'étais avec ti news tillous qui faisait
partie de l'association que j'ai créé
avec kofi annan qui s'appelle cartooning
for peace
voulais me wilhem étaient venus aussi
avec nous en nouvelle zélande on a fait
des rencontres avec des chrétiens des
juifs des musulmans il faut faire un
flashback sur
ce qui s'est passé en 2006 avec les
dessinateurs danois qu'est ce qu'ils ont
fait on peut pas décider sans peut pas
dessiner ça il y en a marre tiens le
jyllands posten le journal danois dit
bientôt on va faire une page on va les
appeler les caricatures de mahomet voilà
un pli en fait c'est pas des caricatures
de mahomet c'est des caricatures de
barbus intolérants
et
en fête les 200 morts au pakistan moi je
vais faire une expo à beyrouth et
l'ambassadeur de 2,2 du liban de france
au liban il dit bon il ya des sacs de
sable autour de l'ambassade il ya des
barbelés il ya des tentes
on va peut-être attendre un peu devait
faire aussi une exposition à islamabad
au pakistan
cela aussi là c'est une ambassadrice qui
me dit bon ben c'est peut-être peut-être
pas le moment encore et donc kofi annan
que je connaissais puisqu'il aimait bien
mes dessins le secrétaire général de
l'onu il me dit mais pourquoi vous ne
mettrez pas ensemble plein de
dessinateurs des chrétiens des juifs des
musulmans alors aux nations unies à new
york et bah comme je les connaissais
tous grâce à l'image du monde je suis
allé partout au japon en amérique latine
en russie en afrique jeudi par prélat
bon je téléphone au bout d'eux j'ai fait
comme mission impossible savez le
téléphone et puis il ya toute l'équipe
qui se fait hélas il y en avait une
bonne vingtaine de dessinateurs des
filles des garçons des chrétiens des
juifs de musulmans des agnostiques et
des athées voilà et puis on a fait une
une association puis on se dit ben voilà
on va essayer de faire des ponts entre
les cultures et c'est plus de cette
manière là que vous voulez agir
notamment pour la paix dans le monde
qu'on publions des dessins que vous
jugeriez trop quoi qui bouscule trop qui
sont trop lentes rhône on est dans une
société où en france il ya le droit au
blasphème c'est très bien il faut garder
ça que l'on puisse
faire des des dessins sur
sur l'essentiel par exemple
moi moreau mais j'en ai rien à
mais par contre les salafistes ça c'est
mon problème et si je peux dessiner
nuit
gravement à la santé avec tabagisme et
nuit gravement à la laïcité salafisme
est ce que je peux le faire dans le
journal je le fais dans le monde là que
ça qui m'intéresse et pour vous c'est
tout aussi fort que de caricatures des
jeunes m c'est ça l'essentiel quand il
ya des petites filles qui sont mutilés
sexuellement au soudan en egypte et pas
que pour eux d'ailleurs me suis rendu
compte que quand je suis allée en egypte
les coptes aussi les orthodoxes les
coptes aussi inutiles les petites filles
il ya plus de 90 % des filles qui sont
mutilés je veux dire moi mon combat
c'est ça mon premier combat c'est
d'essayer de et quand en france
j'apprends qu'il ya des difficultés il
est en france dans les puits au soudan
les pionniers j -p ça se passe en france
c'est bien du boulot quand je vais dans
des écoles il n'y a pas très longtemps
j'étais en corse avec une prof qui me
voyaient la petite fête était en
troisième donc une petite de 3e étaient
partis au maroc elle était revenue était
marié
faut en parler et moi je pense que le
vrai combat
que je veux faire que je veux move c'est
ça c'est ça et quand quand après le même
dessin ou est-ce que je les je l'avais
montré au recteur de la mosquée de paris
vous voyez et le recteur le musulman le
rectum il me reçoit très gentiment il me
dit moussa je me mets à genoux pour que
vous puissiez le publier tout le temps
tout le temps tout le temps il ya on
imagine si une poignée de gens qui sont
incontrôlables
mais il faut absolument les contrôler et
à la fois il faut ne rien lâcher sur les
atteintes aux droits des femmes des
attentes hors droits des petites filles
après on peut dire et quand je fais par
exemple des dessins j'ai fait des
dessins sur le sur la religion les
autres religions oui je fais par exemple
quand je fais tiens par exemple à
dessein je le dis parce que je les fais
il ya une dizaine d'années quand il ya
des des enfants qui sont très bien violé
par des prêtres dans la sacristie je
fais des salages eux le quelle
quelle chance d'avoir un rédacteur en
chef au monde qui le publie à la une du
monde
évidemment tollé général j'ai eu plein
d'ennuis plein de gens qui les ont ni
pour votre sécurité aussi non non non
non non non procès procès procès mais
non pas sécurité
contrairement à d'autres sujets mais à
la fois des dessins comme ça je vous le
dis parce que l'autre jour j'ai
rencontré un gars s'il ya pas longtemps
à oman il me dit je travaille chez tik
tok altimo je connais pas tictoc et
alors il me dit ah ben vous voyez vous
intéressé parce qu'il ya plein de médias
qui alors je regarde stocks je regarde
ça n'a pas loupé jeu comme on parlait la
cassette vidéo pour les très jeunes ni
medécin sur tik tok ce dessin a été
censuré par tik tok ça pas traîner ça
peut être ça pas traîné dire que ce
dessin il est publié dans le monde
problème gros problème d'accord d'accord
et de merlot mais tik tok le bloc et été
pire et pire la sla cela là on va
discuter de l'essentiel 1 seulement
maintenant seulement maintenant mais oui
mais c'est ça notre démocratie pourquoi
elle bascule parce que on s'est mis à
genoux devant des logiciels et des des
algorithmes je suis sûr que chez tik tok
qui savent même pas que les sols le
dessin était censuré il était bloqué par
des algorithmes art des machines part du
chiffre et tant qu'on n'aura pas
légiférer c'est peut-être le lieu on n'a
qu'à demander aux sénateurs de légiférer
d'arrêter de
l'anonymat sur certains réseaux sociaux
plantu savez ça c'est le vrai combat
qu'il faut entamer dès maintenant si on
veut affecter que notre bac notre
démocratie ne bascule et ça va être à
moi de vous montrer quelques images
maintenant
premières photos alors vous avez déjà un
petit peu dit que vous les connaissiez
la caricaturiste j'arrive d'eau là il
s'agit de cabu quand vous le voyez vous
vous dites quoi je le vois presque tous
les jours parce qu'il ya plein de photos
on est tous les deux en forme on fait
des débats et on rigole j'ai encore son
rire incroyable dans les oreilles et à
la fois
comme dit la femme de wolinski maryse
wolinski ce rire de cabu qu'on voit bien
sur cette cette image c'est un rire
d'une époque révolue où on a c'est
maryse qui m'a dit 'ça maryse wolinski
et elle m'a dit on a perdu nos années
d'insouciance
maintenant l'insouciance elle est partie
c'était certainement le plus grand
dessinateur du 20e siècle lui il pouvait
faire un dessin tout de suite même pire
il pouvait faire un dessin comme ça dans
la poche en regardant la fille comme ça
il sortait le papier comme un photomaton
et c'était un dessin impeccable
jamais les vrais amis j'ai un génie j'ai
jamais vu sur une deuxième photo vous le
reconnaissez évidemment il ya sert
arafat oui une grande histoire une drôle
de rencontre will a compté en quelques
secondes la tribune de l'onu là ils
étaient faut dire que faut dire qu'il
était assez facile à décider un
je le connaissais pas lui me connaissait
alors c'est là vous invite à temps je
suis à tunis en 91 vous exposez j'expose
les dessins avec le dessinateur syrien
et dans la nuit à l'hôtel le téléphone
on dit il ya sert arafat qui vous
rencontrer et j'avais complètement
oublié qu'il était à tunis en plus pour
vous dire à quel point j'ai passé mon
temps dans un train dé dans le train
d'or du train et de rentrer dans le
train en tout cas j'ai jamais été dans
la locomotive et
je me retrouve à 4 heures du matin avec
lui et lui qui était pas capable de dire
je reconnais le peuple israélien je
reconnais
l'état israélien il me fait alors
évidemment ça c'est facile le drapeau
est restée bien d'accord mais je lui
tends un feutre bleu pour ça que je me
bats toujours et je me suis tu en as
feutre bleu et mehdi au il va le
faire et il le fait comme ça c'est la
grande histoire que vous écrivez oui
mais à la fois jeu jeudi mais attends je
suis là ce que je sais maintenant que je
suis d'ailleurs je suis dans une villa
de tunis on m'a changé trois fois de
voitures et des kalachnikovs partout et
alors donc presque un an plus tard ou
deux ans plus tard vous fait à peu près
la même chose avec shimon peres et ça il
me signe le dessin jusque là je reviens
à paris en bio web et de rencontrer un
terroriste j'ai passé ma vie j'ai passé
ma vie à me faire engueuler tout le
temps mais je vous assure je vous ai
croyable comme un gamin et puis on m'a
dit oui mais pourrais tu vas pas ça
jérusalem moi je fais un sage uriel je
suis allé voir mitterrand j'ai été voir
védrine qui était réalisé que je
connaissais pas encore une fois et hindi
bah oui baby terran il est d'accord vous
viennent viendra avec lui et vous serez
même dans son avis angélina non je veux
être avec l'avion des journalistes je ne
peux
langer et puis je me sens tout avec
shimon peres qui a terminé le dessin
commenciez par arafat et qu'il a signé
chez bonne période mais là c'est
historique est-ce que la première fois
qu'il signe un même document ouais avant
les accords d'oslo nous langevin se
tient sur incroyable alors je lui ai dit
pour nos téléspectateurs les archives
nationales nous transmettent chaque
semaine un document en lien avec notre
invité et on a pensé à celui ci pour
vous ce sont c'est une caricature du
président armand fallières qui était
président entre 1906 et 1913 danse aux
sénateurs aussi et on a vu on s'est
aperçu qu'ils étaient systématiquement
caricaturé en ivrogne
ça vous fait déjà rire d'alcoolisme
pourtant dans ses quelque chose qui
touche aussi un peu au privé ça fait je
vous donne aussi une montre merci
beaucoup qu'est ce que ça vous inspire
d'abord d'abord comme souvent c'est
quelle année à peu près
1909 6909 à une époque c'est l'assiette
au beurre peut-être c'est paru dans leur
tube heures on gère la cité bourbon
c'est la même époque et tous les
dessinateurs savais dessiner comme des
dieux ils ont une formation à l'école
louis pasteur louis pasteur dont on
parle beaucoup pour eux mais ils
savaient dessinée comme un dieu pourquoi
parce qu'on enseignait dans les écoles
le dessin est à cette époque tout le
monde s'est dessinée c'est pour ça que
ça me fend le coeur quand vous dites je
sais qu'à décider mais je vous le dis
tout le monde s'est dessiné tout le
monde tout le monde n'est pas
michel-ange mais tout le monde s'est
décidé c'était un président de la
république est ce qu'on peut tout faire
même avec un responsable politique le
décès d'un ivrogne
monsieur c'est mignon c'est pas très
méchant je me souviens qu'il y avait un
responsable de la cgt qui s'appelait
krasucki qui buvait que de l'eau en plus
mais comme terminée pas ses phrases sais
pas pourquoi les bons et je le décide et
enivrant et il trouve ça rigolo et ils
m'ont voulait pas oui bon on m'a envoyé
on peut aller une dernière séquence avec
nous puisque on est dans ce lieu magique
entouré de quatre statues qui représente
des vertus et vous allez me dire si vous
trouvé dans celle ci on a la sagesse on
à la prudence on a la justice et on à
l'éloquence alors est-ce qu'il y en a
une qui vous parle il y en a une qui
vous inspire elles sont belles
la prudence j'aime bien le j'aime bien
le deuxième je vous ai parlé de vos
mains quand on est pris dans la tempête
comme ça et elle fait et c'est vrai
c'est amy adams et c'est bien vous
n'êtes pas prudents et
c'est un mélange de folie quand tu es à
gaza avec les gens du hamas on peut pas
dire que je sois vraiment prudent
elle m'intéresse tout via une qui
manquent
l'humilité je trouve que c'est une
époque
où on voyait avec le
la crise sanitaire où tout le monde a
dit tout et n'importe quoi en fait
que soient les médecins que soient les
politiques
les chercheurs tout le monde dédié un
peu des bêtises et tout le monde a
essayé de bien faire malgré tout vous
voyez humilité l'humilité liberté assure
cette vertu oui parce que qu'est ce
qu'ils veulent mais parce que en fait
j'aurais dû le marquer la wii quand je
te rends hommage évidemment à charlie
hebdo évidemment que tout faut rendre
hommage au dessinateur à la fois faut
penser aussi à la cathédrale de nice
faut penser aux mosquées qui sont
souvent
salies dévalisé faut penser aux
synagogues qui sont des fois abîmée par
des connards et donc à la fois liberté
égalité fraternité
d'accord mais moi je dirais liberté
égalité humilité militer ce sera encore
mieux et ce sera le mot de la fin merci
infiniment d'avoir été notre invité dans
un monde un regard merci nous avons
livré une bonne partie de votre monde
c'est la fin de cette émission on se
retrouve bientôt sur public sénat a très
vite
[Musique]